Let's talk about vaccination a little bit.
We're going to cover vaccination in more detail
on an upcoming program as it relates to the
virus.
But today, I want to talk about two prominent
Trump's sycophants who have announced that
they will not accept any coronavirus vaccine
that is associated in any way with Bill Gates.
Now, for me, this entire narrative about the
Belzec benevolent billionaires versus the
evil billionaires.
It's a pretty silly one.
My I apply a more structural understanding
to this issue of billionaires and the sociology
and the economics of billionaires.
I believe most billionaires as people are
pretty good people, but there are systemic
components in our society that favor the very
rich, which often lead to unproductive, self-centered
behavior on the part of billionaires and huge
corporations.
So.
You know, during the Bernie campaign, there
was a lot of discussion about why does this
candidate or that candidate hate billionaires?
And every candidate addressed it differently.
But my view has always been this is not about
billionaires as people.
It's about the positioning of billionaires
and policy in a society that at a structural
level allows and encourages certain behaviors
where you see billionaires created.
And that's really the crux of what we're trying
to deal with.
So my point is talking about these are the
good billionaires and these are the bad billionaires.
Seems like a pretty fraught experiment to
me.
That being said, when you look at Bill Gates
as an individual versus, you know, Koch brothers
as individuals and you look at what Bill Gates
has funded versus the things that Koch brothers
have funded.
In addition, I get Koch brothers, fat fund
medicine and some good things as well.
You look at Bill and Melinda Gates.
They have lobbied other billionaires to give
away as much of their wealth as possible.
Bill Gates has dedicated himself for a very
long time to funding and finding cures and
solutions to everything from sanitation and
developing nations, vaccines for pandemics,
cetera.
Yeah.
Bill Gates doesn't want to pay a wealth tax.
He's a billionaire.
When Elizabeth Warren put out her wealth tax
proposal, he said he scoffed at it.
He balked at it.
Right.
But if we had more billionaires like Bill
Gates than the Koch brothers, we would be
better off.
All else being equal.
So this gets us now to Corona virus.
The Gates Foundation is funding development,
research and possible factories where seven
different Corona virus vaccines could be produced.
Now, this is a huge waste of money in a literal
sense.
And what I mean by that is in order to have
capacity to produce enough vaccines to really
distribute them to enough people to build
herd immunity, you have to take a chance on
an unproven vaccine.
You have to start building infrastructure
to produce unproven vaccines.
There are seven promising vaccine candidates
right now for coronavirus.
Bill Gates is already funding factories to
produce seven different vaccines.
In all likelihood, six of those seven will
not end up being the vaccine.
OK, that's a really good thing that he is
doing.
And his mere involvement in vaccination is
causing conspiracy theory explosions.
A girl I went to high school with has been
posting a lot of this stuff on her Facebook
page.
She's a big trumpet.
I had to unfollow her.
Donald Trump's friends, Diamond and Silk are
spreading the same disinformation.
Take a look at this, including conspiracies
about Bill Gates and population control and
other such nonsense.
We don't need to look at the computer.
Right.
But what we don't need to know happen is what
happened in Africa when Bill Gates took that
vaccine to Africa by trying to vaccinate outlike
stopped to start right there and started parts
of Africa.
That's what we don't need to do, not make
black people not the guinea pig.
But if we can't be yo spare no yo yo project.
Not not yet.
Today, Billy.
Yes.
The surgeon and the surgeon general was talking
to.
As a matter of fact, he was traded today.
Listen up.
Tell us what we need to know.
Yeah, but I always look at the underbelly
of what's going on.
That's my intuition in me.
Yeah, that's my intuitive counterpart.
Yes.
Uh-Huh.
What do you want to do here?
Right.
Because what do you not know?
Do you not go far?
Vaccinating name blackball.
Right.
And we have to have a vaccination card just
to go to.
Do not do that.
And what it does it start with thus far?
Right.
They got us with slavery.
They got us with Jim Crow.
Not about the posters here, man.
That's a nice lesson.
Kodos If you make your vaccines for people
and you want to help.
But I have a problem receiving any vaccine
from any entity, especially anybody like Bill
Gates.
Plus population control.
I think that Margaret Sanger pushed for abortions,
genocide.
Imagine comparing Jim Crow to a corona virus
vaccine.
Again, as I've said before, if people were
only endangering themselves, I would be much
more resigned to a sort of Darwinism in a
sense person as a sort of darwinistic perspective
when it comes to what these people are saying
and doing.
But Diamond and silk have an audience and
they post stuff and people see it and it starts
to spread like a virus itself.
Bill Gates, population control bad for black
people, don't accept any vaccine that Bill
Gates is associated with.
As it is, we are going to have trouble actually
getting the vaccine to everybody, both because
of supply issues and because of existing anti-vax
or sentiment.
And now this on top of it.
So it's much like with the virus, if you don't
social distance, you're putting other people
at risk.
If you convince people not to get the vaccine,
the risk of spread grows exponentially and
our ability to achieve herd immunity is diminished
if you don't get vaccinated.
You are putting other people at risk.
And as we've seen with the measles anti-vaxxers,
when you convince more people not to get a
vaccine, you actually create pockets of outbreaks,
which is exactly what's been happening with
measles.
So this is stunningly ignorant, but dangerous
ignorance in the modern United States of 20/20
is unfortunately common and it's incredibly
applauded in some sick circles.
Donald Trump junior and Donald Trump himself
will often retweet diamond and silk.
They've been to the White House meeting with
Trump like this is really I know I use the
term weaponised too much, so I'm not going
to use it.
But we are in an acute idiocracy and the calls
are coming from inside the house, so
to speak.
Scary, scary stuff.